The graph below contains
the rectangle ABCP.
Draw the image of ABCP under a
dilation whose center is at P
and a scale factor is 1 and 2/3.
What are the lengths of
the side AB and its image?
So we're going to do a
dilation centered at P.
So if we're centering
a dilation at P
and its scale
factor is 1 and 2/3,
that means once we
perform the dilation,
every point is going to be 1 and
2/3 times as far away from P.
Well P is 0 away from
P, so its image is still
going to be at P. So let's put
that point right over there.
Now point C is going
to be 1 and 2/3 times
as far as it is right now.
So let's see, right
now it is 6 away.
It's at negative 3.
And P, its x-coordinate is the
same, but in the y direction,
P is at 3.
C is at negative 3.
So it's 6 less.
We want to be 1 and
2/3 times as far away.
So what's 1 and 2/3 of 6?
Well, 2/3 of 6 is 4, so
it's going to be 6 plus 4.
You're going to be 10 away.
So 3 minus 10, that
gets us to negative 7.
So that gets us
right over there.
Now point A, right
now it is 3 more
in the horizontal direction
than point P's x-coordinate.
So we want to go
1 and 2/3 as far.
So what is 1 and 2/3 times 3?
Well that's going to be 3 plus
2/3 of 3, which is another 2.
So that's going to be 5.
So we're going to
get right over there.
Then we could complete
the rectangle.
And notice point B is
now 1 and 2/3 times
as far in the
horizontal direction.
It was 3 away in the
horizontal direction,
now it is 5 away from
P's x-coordinate.
And in the vertical
direction, in the y direction,
it was 6 below P's y-coordinate.
Now it is 1 and
2/3 times as far.
It is 10 below P's y-coordinate.
So then let's answer
these questions.
The length of segment AB--
well, we already saw that.
That is, we're going
from 3 to negative 3.
That is 6 units long.
And its image, well
it's 1 and 2/3 as long.
We see it over here.
We're going from
3 to negative 7.
3 minus negative 7 is 10.
It is 10 units long.
We got it right.